Traductor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Revisor: Marlén Scholand Cámara
Ani se encuentra
delante de un gran escalera de oro
donde el dios con cabeza de chacal Anubis
está pesando su corazón
en contra de una pluma de avestruz puro.
Ani fue una persona real,
un escriba de la ciudad egipcia de Tebas
que vivió en el siglo XIII a.C.
y aquí representado es una escena
de su Libro de los Muertos,
un rollo de papiro de 24 m diseñado
para ayudarle a alcanzar la inmortalidad.
Tales textos funerarios fueron escritos
originalmente solo para los faraones,
pero con el tiempo,
los egipcios llegaron a creer
que la gente normal también
podía llegar a la otra vida
si tenían éxito en el camino.
El viaje épico de Ani
comienza con su muerte.
Su cuerpo está momificado
por un equipo de sacerdotes
que eliminan todos los órganos,
excepto el corazón,
el asiento de las emociones,
la memoria y la inteligencia.
Luego se llena con una sal llamada natrón
y envuelve en lino empapado en resina.
Además, las envolturas se tejen
con amuletos para la protección
y se rematan con un amuleto
de corazón de escarabajo
que será importante más adelante.
El objetivo del proceso de dos meses es
preservar el cuerpo de Ani de forma ideal
con el que su espíritu con el tiempo
pueda reunirse.
Pero en primer lugar, el espíritu debe
atravesar el Duat o bajo mundo.
Este es un reino de vastas cavernas,
lagos de fuego,
y puertas mágicas,
todos vigilado por las bestias temibles.
Serpientes, cocodrilos y
monstruosidades media humanas
con nombres como
"el que baila en la sangre."
Para empeorar las cosas, Apep,
el dios serpiente de la destrucción,
se esconde en las sombras
esperando a tragarse el alma de Ani.
Afortunadamente, Ani se prepara
con la magia contenida
en su libro de los muertos.
Al igual que otros egipcios
que podían permitírselo,
Ani incluyó en su pergamino a su medida
particulares hechizos, oraciones y códigos
que pensaba que
su espíritu podía necesitar.
Equipado con este arsenal,
nuestro héroe atraviesa los obstáculos,
repele los actos de los monstruos,
y sigilosamente evita Apep
para llegar a la sala de Maat,
diosa de la verdad y la justicia.
Aquí, Ani se enfrenta a su desafío final.
Es juzgado por 42 dioses evaluadores
que deben estar convencido
de que él ha vivido una vida recta.
Ani se acerca a cada uno
dirigiéndose a ellos por su nombre,
y declarando un pecado
que no ha cometido.
Entre estas confesiones negativas
o declaraciones de inocencia,
proclama que él
no ha hecho llorar a nadie,
no es un espía,
y no ha contaminado el agua.
Pero ¿Realmente Ani vivió
una vida tan perfecta?
No del todo, pero ahí entra el amuleto
del escarabajo del corazón en acción.
Inscrito con las palabras: "No se pare
en calidad de testigo en mi contra"
precisamente para que el corazón
de Ani no le traicionara
recordando el momento
en que escuchó a sus vecinos a combatir
o lavar sus pies en el Nilo.
Ahora, es el momento de la verdad
de Ani, el peso del corazón.
Si su corazón es más pesado que la pluma,
lastrado por las malas acciones de Ani,
será devorado por el monstruo Ammit,
parte cocodrilo, parte leopardo,
que forma parte de hipopótamo,
y Ani dejará de existir para siempre.
Pero Ani tiene suerte.
Su corazón se juzga puro.
Ra, el dios del sol, lo lleva a Osiris,
dios del mundo subterráneo,
que le da la aprobación final
para entrar en la vida futura.
En el campo sin fin y exuberante de cañas,
Ani se encuentra
con sus padres fallecidos.
Aquí, no hay tristeza, dolor o ira,
pero hay trabajo por hacer.
Como todos los demás, Ani
debe cultivar una parcela de tierra,
lo que hace con ayuda de una muñeca
Shabti que colocada en su tumba.
Hoy en día, el Papiro de Ani
reside en el Museo Británico,
donde ha estado desde 1888.
Solo Ani, si alguien, sabe lo que
realmente sucedió después de su muerte.
Pero gracias a su Libro de los Muertos,
podemos imaginarlo feliz atendiendo
sus cosechas por toda la eternidad.